hey I was going for us my name is Tampa
gross expand the pros qtpie myself here
I think do your intro yeah yeah I know
okay
thing is fender bros it's only local
co-op that's why I'm playing in Butte
thank you you're what
oh yeah we have to reach yes doctor
right yes
oh you jump with it all right all right
all right all right all right
brother brother way that for me you're
adding pz7 stop it's a ball it's my team
just about teamwork um dance might say
it's up to you what what is that stop
yeah why do you talk to me rest in peace
bro stop touching Levi's bud so you can
sniffing and kiss it yes n-no yeah it's
my my wife flex yeah Oh gross yeah
flexing complete bro Caesar yeah welcome
bro Caesar whoa ha ha ha ha good job
you're doing it your natural-born killer
you really are is kind of disturbing
dammit I died god damn it now now don't
leave that me yeah I have to kill him
yeah I don't know what you're doing but
you're searching for you what if I you
gosh
go up and kill everything you know what
it's still you that's bull trash if you
kill the guy with the radio they will
stop come now my god
I wish I have did do it oh my god whoo
you did it you did okay yeah yeah yeah
just get the helicopter now it's not
fair as I try so hard and you
snake-headed now against it I'm great
now you're great I know what I'm doing I
cry with you I can go down to you yeah
baby yeah I'm gonna try there you go
you're back in action baby yeah yeah bro
yeah that's awesome bro we gotta kill
the sky in the tower
this kind of towered this guy in the
time think I died Jesus Chris Mike get
in
Ginter get in wait how do I write him
I'm writing him yes
Oh God
no he's fine don't worry yeah bro thanks
bro sighing I don't know how do you get
up there
oh my god you're Pro you may gonna look
bad all right look at this look at this
guy
now wait number that wasn't cool don't
it don't look don't look at what nah
that's all right that's all right
oh my god you're okay now oh my god what
are you doing what exactly is the fine
here you are doing it are you right yeah
good good
no I'm not leaving well my bro never
never leaving in my Brad my Brad we're
out your breath where where are you
Brown call that for me I know you can
hear me bro rah you're free and then
again
retro I got one too
don't touch me
I'm so done we're breaking it how could
you thank you for watching this video
leave a like to become a pro or an
expand the problem and we will see you
in the next one brofist yeah he
container oh my god
burn baby burn America huh